[Music]
all right let's go out to betone R and
talk to uh Baton Rouge and talk to
Heather what's up
Heather hey Dr John thank you so much
for for taking my call I'm doing okay I
wanted to tell you first of all just how
much my husband and I both just
appreciate you and all the work that
you're doing I finished your book
building a non-anxious life last night
actually and um it's it's been helping
me so much and so thank you for that and
thank you um yes so I'm hoping um yeah
I'm choosing freedom and with that I'm
gonna go into my question and all right
let's do it hopefully um you can yeah
help me out all right so uh my question
is how do I love and respect my parents
and other extended family
members while setting boundaries to
protect my marriage and my
children and um to give you some
background I can um just talk about a
recent event that happened when we were
visiting my family recently yeah go for
it um all right
so
um so we Face we faced these issues
several times once when we visit my
family but became a little more obvious
this time with my dad um he tends to
be just usually annoyed with our kids
when we're there like by the noise they
make the messes they make he speaks in a
belittling and condescending way not
just to my children but he's always
spoken that way to my mom and um to us
as kids and um
um many people so that that's an issue
that's seems to be getting worse and
then my mom um doesn't always agree with
our parenting Styles and thinks we
should just turn on the TV anytime the
kids are getting rowy and we really try
to limit screen time and my husband and
I felt led to become Catholic this year
so that's something that we're kind of
on a journey on and so we take like
prayer and going to church very
seriously and when we get our kids up in
the morning when we're there to go to
church she gets upset by the fact that
we're not spending time with them that
we're going to
church and then um the last last um
relationship that we kind of deal with
when we're there is my sister and her
kids um she kind of gives her kids full
access to phones internet and her kids
are a little bit older than hours and
they're learning about my 9-year-old
niece has already learned about like
what sex is and um so we have kids that
are much younger and so we're just
trying to um protect them and feels like
when when we go we're kind of just
having to constantly kind of monitor our
kids and protect them from things that
are happening around their house so just
hoping that you can give me some
guidance on how I can
how we can still build a relationship
with them but like how to set boundaries
with them yeah you bet um all right so
there's a couple things here um one just
off top of my head nine-year-olds should
know about
sex um that should be an ongoing
conversation uh but they should not find
out about it via their cell phones or
the internet they should find out about
that from trusting adults in their life
so that was just an aside um all right
so I think we've got love and resp
respect all sideways okay love and
respect requires as a fundamental core
Principle as a as a building block a
Cornerstone of love and respect is
boundaries love and respect does not
mean that you have to do whatever
somebody else wants of
you okay yeah so if you grew up in a
home where you're always
belittled and your dad flexed on the
people that he was supposed to
love that meant that y'all's job was to
curate a world where Dad was never his
feathers were never
ruffled because he was a peacock who
liked to really shine and kick up those
tail feathers so the goal of the house
Mom you your siblings the goal was to
keep the peace right yes exactly okay
mom has been putting up with this for
what 25 30 years how old are you uh I'm
33 they've been married for 40 years
okay so for 4 years her job every day is
to make sure he's not pissed
off that's how she stayed safe that's
how she stayed quote unquote out of
trouble that's how she manufactured a
little pocket of safety inside of her
world okay so let's set that over to the
side for a
second often when people grow up in that
I mean are are in a relationship like
that they um look to the next lowest
person on the rung if you will and they
extract that
similarly but they often do it from the
bottom up not the top down here's what I
mean your dad is huge he comes over the
top he's a big loud male and he may be
five foot2 I don't know how big he is
but he's got this presence that is I
can't tell those kids to be quiet or he
doesn't say anything that way he can
kind of uh act indignant when somebody
calls him on it but he gets all tense
and he goes around huffing and puffing
and picking up the the toys that the
kids left out really heavy right um yeah
or he goes sh real loud like he's just
real abrasive mom on the other hand
is Oh you mean you're just going to go
to church and we're just not going to
have breakf okay I guess I'll just I
guess we'll just Eat Here by ourselves
then um if that's more important to you
then um okay it's the same exact move
just underneath the boat she's dragging
it underneath it instead of on top of it
is that ring a bell yes yes it does okay
so that is one person who has been using
the other person to get the life he
wants not as a partnership but as a
basically a um an extended parent and
then your mom does that to the next
lowest person which is her kids
okay so everything is about peace and
everything's about comfort and what you
and your husband have chosen to do
is to do something opposite to head into
a relationship with your kids which is
messy and hard it is easy to dump them
in front of a TV you know why how I know
that I did it last night yeah my wife
and my son were out at a at a church
event my daughter was chaos and I needed
to finish some stuff and I said hey you
know what I know it's a school night do
you want to go watch a show and her eyes
lit up and she was like oh my gosh dude
she ran up there you know what I got
done in that 30 minutes I got so much
done
and it wasn't that big of a deal on a
one-off but if that was my default every
day all the time I'd be failing my kid
right y'all have chosen to not do that
you have chosen to head into it how old
are your
kids six three and two okay you know
what six three and two year olds are
loud yeah and running around and chaotic
and they break things and they test
things and they're curious and they hit
the their head on things and they don't
put things away that doesn't mean that
y'all are failing that doesn't mean that
means y'all are growing kids that H are
using the whole world as a laboratory
for how things work and how things feel
right yes and your parents are opting
out of that
world you also have chosen to not give
your kids unac unfettered access to the
internet I've chosen not to let them be
raised by screens your sister's not made
that choice and so she's opting out of
their
life here's what this
means I cannot love and respect somebody
if every time I'm around them I'm on
defense or I'm slowly being
suffocated okay yeah so the best way I
can love and respect somebody is to have
clear and firm and loving
boundaries that doesn't mean avoidance I
think we have used the word as avoidance
is I can never be in contact with you
and I think that's an overreaction
particularly by younger Generations I
don't think we have to do that but I'll
go hang out with you and I'm G to be
really clear hey if you say that joke
about these people I'm I don't want to
be around it I'm gonna leave and then
they'll make the joke and you'll go all
right hey guys y'all take it easy I'm
out are you serious yeah yeah I was
pretty clear about that that's just I
don't think it's funny I'm out youall
have a good one guys and I'll catch
youall next time and I'll come back
those are my friends those are my family
members and I'm going to be clear again
hey just FYI and if they do it again
then what they're saying is we don't
want you here we would rather tell this
joke about this group of people than
have you here that's what they're
saying yeah I found out that there's a
group of my friends who I love who have
different jokes when I'm around than
when I'm not and you know what I
freaking love that because that is so
respectful of my
boundaries you know what I'm saying yeah
so similarly I think it's worth a very
direct in a very loving conversation
you're 33 years old you have three kids
how long have you been
married n and a half years almost a
decade you know what it's time for
grown-up conversations with
grown-ups yeah that's a coffee taking
your dad out to Coffee hey Dad can I
take you out to Coffee
sure hey Dad every time my kids come
over to your house there going to be a
hard
conversation everything about your body
language tells me you don't want us here
and you don't want them here that
somehow you think I'm failing as a
parent and I actually think I'm a pretty
good parent and my kids are
great but you belittle us you talk down
to us you get mad at us and here's the
thing I want them to have you in their
life but I can't have
that and me saying that to you you
imagining yourself having that
conversation what does it feel
like uh it doesn't feel comfortable it
I've I haven't had a conversation about
this exact thing but I I have had
conversations when I bring things up to
my dad in the past and it it doesn't go
well okay he he plays it down he turns
it back on me and doesn't doesn't listen
do you have that in the moment or off to
the side like in a pre-arranged
time uh I can remember specifically one
time in college when I like specifically
just pulled him off to the side when he
was reading or something and tried to
have a conversation with them and okay
well I my recommendation is to try it
again just and this is why you're you
want to know that you entered into an
uncomfortable situation and you retained
your dignity and you treated everybody
with love and
respect and I think love and respect
often requires
discomfort and honesty and Clarity if
you just disappear and decide to not go
I think that can be cruel
and end you end up becoming just like
him and instead of belittling him to his
face like he does to you you belittle
him under the water he sucks I don't
want him around our kids we're not going
to go anywhere now I have a rule that I
only talk if somebody is going to hear
me I don't speak just to have spoken
that's what the social media world is
that's
politicians um I don't speak if I if I
can't be heard and so if you think in
your in your guts dude he can't hear a
word I'm saying cool don't have that
conversation and same with your mom I
think it's worth taking Mom out for a
coffee and saying hey
Mom we have drawn a line when it comes
to
screens we're just not going to do it
it's not how we're going to raise our
kids it's not and so I want that to stop
being an expectation in this house and I
understand if our kids are too loud then
we're just going to we're just going to
not have them here we're going to not
have them here and we're going to roll
out but all that to say is whatever your
boundaries happen happen to be the way
you demonstrate that you love and
respect your parents is by being very
clear kind respectful if Poss I mean
always respectful but kind if possible
have the clear conversation and then
they get to respond however they want to
immature like you said turn it back on
you blame
you and my God how how heartbreaking and
lame it is for a child to sit down with
their parent and say hey here's how I
experience you and for them to make it
their kid's fault so ridiculous and I
hate that that happen to you I hope it
didn't happen
again your sister's kids are handing out
phones and your 9-year-olds talking
about sex with a six-year-old and you're
not comfortable then dude then don't
have them around cool have maybe have a
conversation with your sister hey tell
your nine-year-old to stop talking about
sex with us with our with my kids please
have that conversation are you kidding
me yeah I'm I'm I mean no I'm not
kidding that's a big deal to me and
here's the deal they may all opt out of
relationship with you for a season that
will hurt so
bad but kind of like surgery to get out
the cancer get out a tumor they have to
cut you they have to cause you pain hurt
your body if you will to get out the bad
stuff if your family opts out it will
hurt but it will also be removing a
group of people who say they love you on
one hand and spit on your boundaries and
value and the
other so it's going to hurt it's going
to be painful you're going have to
grieve it and puts an end to this
madness or what I think's going to
happen is as a 33-year-old who's been
married for a decade with three young
kids they might hear you and I would
start the conversation like this this is
really hard for me I'm scared to have
this conversation I'm nervous about it
so I'm going to Fumble through it a
little
bit but I'm going to ask that you please
treat me as an adult as I as we talk
through
this I know that's in this guy for some
of you listen you're just laughing
you're like dude my dad would never hear
that call but I think it would shock you
how many parents would be honored pain
hurt but honored to be approached that
way by their adult kids most people want
to be connecting most of the time they
just don't know how and if you have this
conversation and give your parents a
road map at least you're giving them a
chance thank you so so much for the call
Heather I'm really really grateful for
you